is it just me or how often is anyone
else in most third person shooters in
general at least the ones I play how
many of you feel like the dude in the
bathroom in Pulp Fiction and zombies are
like did you feel something no yeah
maybe I suck there's a sweet game
[Music]
Resident Evil 2 so Resident Evil 2 is a
remake from the ground up of the
PlayStation 1 classic Resident Evil 2
whether they did the ground-up thing
with two not one but one's gotten a few
remakes rhe skins whatever I was glad to
see to get some love that's right this
being a remake you have the same story
as Resident Evil 2 you play as either
Leon Kennedy or Claire Redfield play
this path with Claire that's one way to
play the game this path with Leon see
what he was doing by played Claire a and
Leon B I mean the PlayStation you could
do Claire a Leon B and then Leon a
Claire base that's essentially four
paths to play the game I don't know if
the remake does that but I don't see why
wouldn't I just haven't done I've done
Claire a Leon B and this is what a
remake is supposed to be that this
benefits the game but in Resident Evil 2
for the PlayStation was amazing and it
actually does show in the fact that they
didn't change too much up they updated
it shirt updated the gameplay updated
the graphics but a lot of the plot you
will recognize from the original the
layout some of the rooms I was like
that's the same exact room from the
original so it really shows how great
Resident Evil 2 was but they were like
we don't have to change everything we
just have to bring you the 2009 date the
camera being over the shoulder puts you
in the shoes of the character but like
Resident Evil 7 now with Resident Evil 2
I hope capcom realizes what Resident
Evil is which is not an action game keep
it survival horror that's what people
love but when I say you're in the shoes
of the characters man you are when the
lights are off and you have your
flashlights like that's more intense
than the PlayStation 1 Resident Evil 2
was and the original Resident Evil 2 had
a lot of intense moments point is this
remake of the sequel to the game that
essentially created a genre survival
horror that belongs to Resident Evil
Resident Evil 2 does its own genre proud
and like the original you got to
conserve your ammo it's not an action
game either a couple of firefights that
are hardcore but some of the enemies
they have weak spots okay
how many shots to the head kind of
zombie
take before it ceases to be a zombie and
is now a demigod shoot him in the head
that's the rule right [ __ ]
zombies so many rounds in the head and
they live and that's if I actually end
up shooting them because this game
uncharted did it all so it's not just me
right is this familiar but Resident Evil
games aren't supposed to be action games
this is not an action game this is a
horror game it's a puzzle game actually
quite cerebral some other puzzles it's
Dawn of the Dead Meets The Thing
Resident Evil 2 was next level in horror
for video games so I'm glad Resident
Evil 2 got this love and I'm glad this
love this remake actually elevated it
not all the weapons are back though like
Claire doesn't have her crossbow not
gonna lie not missing it though I mean
these things take seven shots to the
head before they die the crossbow is
always kind of a [ __ ] weapons of what
I wasn't missing it give me the acid
rounds any day I do like the ammo system
where you do find individual ammo but
then you find these ammo components you
can mix them to make the ammo you really
need don't you kind of form your ammo
towards your gameplay style
that's why I've learned to take out a
zombie though you shoot them a couple
times in the head when they drop go over
with the knife he's [ __ ] shaken you
slash them until you hear that weird
gross sound in another day only a couple
of bullets use a bit of knife save your
ammo the game's hard dude I'm not gonna
lie like with the amount of shots these
enemies take I was running low on ammo
there's a point in the game where you're
like there's not enough famil in this
game I'm just gonna die in this police
station which is what I'm supposed to
feel like the tyrant is also in this
game tyrant was in the original Resident
Evil 2 he's in here this is big dude
that's just casing the place looking for
you trying to kill you yeah you can
waste some ammo on him best to run
because even when he takes a Nene rest
he ain't down he's gonna come back for
you and that's the hard lesson this game
teaches you with games like this I
usually like to just annihilate and
eliminate everything around me every
threat has to go down Resident Evil 2
though you're like I need to run
humbling absolutely but it's also
realistic because that's how it would go
down I do miss the fact that in the
original Resident Evil 2 the tyrant
would just bust through the wall like
wow oh my god he's right there so that's
a sacrifice in my eyes I like the fact
this tyrant would just bust through the
wall and
Wow unexpected gotta fight him from my
recollection in the original Resident
Evil 2 when you beat him up and he takes
a knee he's kind of gone until he bust
through another wall and you got to face
him again in this game he's just always
there you could always hear him to just
boom the closer you are the louder his
footsteps are at first I was like well
that kind of sucks ass I was just this
guy's just always around that's annoying
I'll have a goal he'll be in that room
and I can't get the goal I can't do the
puzzle I can't get the piece or gonna
like what guide them away of their
liquors their two liquors and the tyrant
are you quiet do you stay still so the
liquor doesn't kill you or do you run
past them the liquor will attack you but
then you can run from the tyrant these
are the tough choices Resident Evil 2
forces you to make correct answer is run
the [ __ ] out of there but on my second
playthrough I was really familiar with
the police station you find the hiding
spots that you can go to he won't
actually go into that room and you just
sit there you sit there like it's a
quiet place or something you're just
like it's pretty damn frightening and it
makes the threat very much alive
so the tyrant not crashing through the
wall surprising the [ __ ] out of you just
out of nowhere it felt like a loss to me
for that not to be in here but with that
loss we gained something else something
more something bigger and that is a
threat that is very much alive because
this tyrant is continuously casing this
police station he's always in it he's
always around just the threat is always
there you hear the footsteps behind the
door you got to get behind the door
don't go another way find another way I
don't know if it's because of the
addition I got or a preorder bonus but I
could select the original PlayStation
soundtrack like the music from the
PlayStation 1 game could play in the
game just normally organically and I'll
be completely honest I like filling the
PlayStation 1 soundtrack cuz it's a
great soundtracks really appealing it
mixes well with the tone has that
PlayStation 1 synthesized tone going on
for horror I bathed in nostalgia gave me
that PlayStation 1 soundtrack it was
awesome also there are variant costumes
I got with Leon I just kept him as is
Claire Redfield got the Elsa Walker
outfit I just kept that outfit on Claire
Redfield the entire time because down
with the thickness I'm just being real
anyone who did that play in the game you
look yeah no he's right the thing that's
really cool in one hand but kind of a
bummer on the other because they didn't
do more with it is the fact that this
Resident Evil 2 remake like the original
it has two paths my first playthrough
path a was with Claire so when I'm
talking
about this when I said Claire that's
what I mean to play through with Claire
you meet up with Leon Leon's doing
something else what's he doing you beat
it with Claire then you unlock Leon's
run I think they call it the second run
so after you beat it with Claire you
play that unlock mode and then you see
what Leon was doing sounds really cool
the maps are the same but the paths are
different also they have two very
different end bosses you have to beat
the game with both to get the true
ending but I wish the two scenarios were
more interconnected I wish what I did
and Claire's playthrough affected what
happened in Leon's playthrough if you
don't do that at least don't have me
fight the same sub bus like with Claire
there's a scenario where William Birkin
or gee they just call it geez the
monster is like trying to stab me
through the ceiling his [ __ ] man
claws coming through and she's trying to
kill me
by the end of this scenario the ceiling
is just wrecked which sounds great and
then I got there with Leon I had to do
the same thing ceiling was fine and he's
trying to stab me and kill me through
the ceiling and then the ceiling was
wrecked the fact that I have to go
through that scenario with both
characters makes it feel
compartmentalized if this scenario was
how it's supposed to be which is you
play through with Claire then you see
what Leon was doing when you're Leon in
the second run you come through that
room the room should be just destroyed
you're worth of our government here as
it stands I had to do the same thing
with both character in the same room
with the same sub boss which makes them
feel unlinked and doesn't really make
much sense to me if I'm playing two
paths that are happening parallel to
each other but my Leon path definitely
had its own stuff like the crocodiles in
it didn't run into that with Claire that
that was a Leon specific thing for me so
I'm glad to have their differences I
just wish they didn't have some of the
things that were the same but those are
like nitpicks those are the wishful
things like I wish they had done that
had done that doesn't take away from the
fact that what they did with this game
was great it took me back in all the
rightness talvik ways but also stands on
its own as its own great game it in and
of itself is a great horror game a great
survival horror game creepy atmosphere
fantastic tone the game isn't really
that long my first playthrough with
Claire took me about eight hours that
was still me figuring out the layout
then with Leon it took me about six and
a half or seven hours put them together
even then it's not a very long game but
it's damn enjoyable we can't all be the
olympus mons of video games which is Red
Dead Redemption - yeah I haven't even
beaten that because it's daunting at a
point you're like it's so sometimes you
want a fantastic game to enjoy yourself
with maybe scare the [ __ ] out of you and
won't take up all of your time Resident
Evil 2 is totally that and Resident Evil
2 the remake and the original but for
the sake of this review the remake is
awesome
you'll a great tone great horror fun
game time efficient hi so Resident Evil
2 have you played it what did you think
about it how does it compare to the
original for you whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]